some of our favorite on-screen enemies
are actual real-life besties
while some actors can't stand each other
many actors choose to live with their
fellow cast members sophie Turner and
Maisie Williams were so close they
started excluding the rest of the game
of Thrones cast and some Outer Banks
pugs and kook's decided to spend
quarantined together I just made a
breakfast as Betty Cooper and she'll
blossom on Riverdale these two don't
exactly see eye to eye but behind the
scenes Lily Reinhart and Madeline pêche
were actually living as roommates for a
time during the first season they stayed
together while filming in Vancouver Lily
says she knows Madeleine always has her
back and admits they spend a lot of time
talking about their personal lives and
romantic relationships so apparently
there's exciting gossip going on behind
the scenes on Riverdale they even got
together for some quarantine crafts and
helped each their friends had a tie-dye
I have social anxiety as well when we
lived together Jakob the Lord he's made
Jacobs isn't exactly the best love
character on yuphoria and hands and a
Ezra Bennet aren't exactly besties it's
kind of this protagonist antagonist
kinda thing but the on-screen tensions
disappear backstage where the cast
members are incredibly close with one
another we were like a tight-knit family
so I mean we spend so many hours on set
when they're not pretending to be ruined
Nate these two were so close that many
fans think they're more than just
friends Jacob did tell GQ Australia and
zendaya is like his sister in addition
to being an amazing creative but they
were also spotted looking cozy in New
York City and is Jacob kissing her head
in this pic maybe he meant little sister
in the Game of Thrones way and speaking
of that famous Fantasy franchise I
didn't betray Rob I didn't betray our
entire family for my beloved Joffrey
Game of Thrones stars sophie Turner and
Maisie Williams went through a phase
when they might have been a little bit
too close sisters Sansa and Arya Stark
didn't get along for most of the show
but backstage was totally different but
they were so determined to pack in as
much friendship time as possible that
they were accidentally ignoring their
other co-stars whoops they grew up
together and were ecstatic when their
characters finally found their way back
to each other and they could reunite on
set not that the rest of the cast was
necessarily as enthusiastic as they were
oh I don't think anyone like to other
than us how many episodes of
Victoria's did it take for Tori Vega and
Jade West to become kind of friends they
were caught up in a rivalry over Jade's
boyfriend back Oliver left behind the
scenes Victoria justice and elizabeth
gillies were surprisingly close they
even used quarantine to reconnect with
their other victorious co-stars
including Ariana Grande Matt Bennett and
moreover um zoom call Liz also said
she'd be open to the possibility of a
victorious reunion as long as the
original cast was involved yes that's
something that I always said I would
clear my schedule for Kristen Stewart
and Dakota Fanning worked together on
the runaways but are better known for
their appearances in the massively
popular Twilight franchise Edward may
have been crazy about Bella
but Valtteri agent Jane not so much when
Dakota introduced Kristen and Elle's
women and Hollywood Awards in 2016
she described her friendship with
Kristen as one of the most special bonds
in her life and said she'd been a
constant supportive presence since the
two of them met she said Kristen has
always encouraged her to be yourself and
it's clear the two of them are
incredibly close most of all I admire
the woman I have watched you become we
know Voldemort is the big fattie of the
Harry Potter series but it's certainly
easy to hate on Draco Malfoy who's no
angel either in real life Tom couldn't
be more unlike Draco as evidenced by the
fact that he's so close with the cast
with Draco have ever been seen hanging
out with Neville Longbottom well Matthew
Lewis and Tom are actually good friends
so much so that they love to tease each
other and social media when Tom
complained about aging
Matthew piped up with speak for yourself
lad a reference to Matthew's famous
glow-up good friends support each other
but true friends know how to tease each
other too would you like my dog Sharpay
and Gabriella were rivals in the High
School Musical franchise and Ashley
Tisdale and vanessa Hutchens have
managed to stay friends since the series
ended Vanessa describes Ashley as a
loyal person and says she fully expects
them to be friends forever even when
they can't get together they find ways
to stay in touch like when Vanessa
posted a tick tock duet
alongside Ashley's performance of we're
all in this together Franklin
in theater that means good luck when
Taylor Swift chose Selena Gomez to
appear in the music video for bad blood
it was because they were actually
friends rather than enemies
they've been pals for over a decade and
Selena says they clicked instantly when
they met through their van boyfriends
Joe and Nick Jonas Selena also claims
Taylor taught her how she should be
treated by guys while Taylor says she
could never forgive someone for hurting
Selena apparently they've gone through
similar experiences in their dating
lives and were able to support each
other through these hard times
Oh Dov Cameron's mal is the star of The
Descendants franchise but there's one
fellow cast member she admits to being
jealous of and it just so happens to be
one of her good friends we're talking
about Sarah Jeffery whose character
princess Audrey got to go full-on evil
in a third movie dov admits to being
envious that Sarah got to go all out
while Dov had to be the much more
responsible protagonist but it seems
there are no hard feelings since dove
Sarah and the rest of the descendants
cast are super close it's been four
years now and we've made lifelong
friends
Steve Harrington on stranger things
proved that sometimes life is hard for
the handsome popular guy well especially
when dem accordions are involved he was
dumped by his girlfriend Nancy wheeler
who immediately started dating Jonathan
Byers the guy she told him not to worry
about and in real life Natalija dire and
Charley Heaton are a couple who have
been spotted on a double date with Joe
Keary and his girlfriend make him on row
Joe and Natalie are our good friends and
claimed their relationship makes
enduring red carpets a lot easier Harry
Potter fans know Hermione and Draco
aren't exactly pals but behind the
scenes
emma watson has admitted that tom Felton
was her first crush apparently the two
of them talked about it and she got over
it by the third movie or at least that's
what they claimed their co-star Rupert
Grint claimed there was a spark between
them and Tom and Emma do spend a lot of
time together including the time they
took a vacation in South Africa they're
so close it's no wonder there's no
shortage of dating rumors concerning
their relationship could you ever see
the two of them together yeah kid it was
always something you think Simon spoke
in Outer Banks there's a divide between
the wealthy cooks and the working-class
post now regardless of whether you're
kook or Pope pretty much everyone agrees
raff Cameron is kind of the worst
good thing drew Starkey is nothing like
his character and got incredibly close
to his fellow cast members while working
on the show it was one of the greatest
crews and cast combinations I've ever
worked with on the set he even spent
some time in quarantine with them
including his good friend Rudy Pankow
who plays JJ one of RAF's many many
enemies this quarantine crew also
included Madeline Kline and chase Hudson
who claim there may also have been
blanket forts involved in this situation
Justin Prentiss betrayed Bryce Walker on
13 reasons why and he wasn't exactly a
hit with his fellow Liberty High
students to say the least at least he
wasn't by the time season three rolled
around one of his many enemies was Zack
Dempsey who happened to be played by
Justin's good friend and have even joked
about starting a holiday-themed boy band
with fellow 13 reasons why cast members
Timothy granite Darrow's and Tyler
Barnhart let's just say that Ray and
kylo Ren had a complicated relationship
in the Star Wars franchise they may have
started out as enemies but Daisy Ridley
and Adam driver have always been
supportive of each other Adam and Daisy
aren't sure how Railly would work out
but they do know that their real-life
BFFs
it's easy to be in scenes with her
because I could I could listen to her
you know all day Michael B Jordan played
the villain Erik kill monger Stevens in
Black Panther but he couldn't resist
getting close to his cast mate Lupita
Nyong'o who plays Nakia not only I be
great friends but they had a secret bet
going and at one point Michael had to do
a push-up whenever Lupita requested one
including at a fashion show these two
have a fun and playful partnership that
they insist is strictly platonic
Lily Reinhart and Madeline pêche aren't
the only Riverdale cast members who have
spent time as roommates despite decades
of animosity between their comic book
characters Archie and Reggie KJ Appa and
Charles Melton are roomies these two are
great friends and who aren't afraid to
say I love you in public or on the red
carpet JJ even said he would marry
Charles if he had to pick a Riverdale
cast member to commit to if I were to
marry one of them I would probably marry
Charles on the set of spider-man far
from home Tom Holland and Jake
Gyllenhaal learned to appreciate each
other hey
I'm spider-man is that supposed to be
funny
spider-man and Mysterio may have had
their differences but these two stars
admit to missing each other while they
are part being chopped in a labyrinth
ala The Maze Runner would be a nightmare
but it would be slightly less awful to
be stuck there with a friend Thomas and
Gowdy may not be besties but the same
can't be said for Dylan O'Brien and will
Poulter Dylan claims they're good
friends off screen and even on set they
constantly check in on each other to
make sure they're feeling okay I like
this fight you've ever seen yeah yes
full of sorry's in my bag Lena Headey
and Peter Dinklage were BFS before they
played sparring siblings Searcy and
Tyrion Lannister on Game of Thrones in
fact Peter was the one who convinced the
producers that Lena would make the
perfect Evil Queen they bunked with each
other during filming and have remained
close for many years according to Amy
Richardson who played Marcela Baratheon
their fun back and forth made things
more relaxed for everyone on set okay so
maybe Daenerys Targaryen and the
wildling you gret never had a chance to
meet on Game of Thrones but it's safe to
say they wouldn't exactly have gotten
along but behind the scenes Emilia
Clarke and Rose Leslie are pals who even
went on vacation together Emilia is also
close with roses husband Kit Harington
who plays John Snow the ex of both
Daenerys and you gret on the show you
know Newton Johnny Smith
could you tell that these on-screen
enemies didn't really hate each other or
were you surprised to learn they're
behind the scene friendships are there
any stars you think should be best
friends let us know what you think in
the comment section below and don't
forget to click on the subscribe button
and turn on your notifications for more
new videos from us here at the things
thanks for watching and we'll see you
again next time
[Music]
you